[Music]
compute is one of the foundation
services of AWS in fact I was attending
one of the trainings at AWS and they
told us that 73 percent of total revenue
of AWS is through ec2 that's a server in
the cloud a compute in the cloud so
let's look at four offerings among many
that compute gives us so the first one
is lightsail and there are people who
love to build their servers have their
databases put on the firewall settings
and then install a lot of things but
then on the other hand there are people
who simply want something out of the box
and they don't want to provision a
server to do everything on end and they
want it for a monthly small price for
all those use cases we have something
called light sale which is one of the
newest services launched by AWS and the
plan starts at about $5 a month and it
involves the VM the storage the data
transfer you can access search it from
the console and you can have a static IP
or DNS management right from the console
and you don't need to worry about it
we'll take a look at it in our demo
section then we have ec2 so this is
where you install any application that
you would want this is essentially the
compute in the cloud where they have
virtualized your services and then you
can access it anywhere from the world
using the internet they have multiple
pricing options on demand and reserve on
the spot so if you have your workload
which you know is going to run for a
very long time one year two years three
years you can go ahead pay upfront
reserve that thing and get 75% off they
have something called spot option where
all of the unused capacity that AWS has
for compute they put it on auction and
then you can put your price over there
and then you can probably get close to
90% off
and then it is used for large workloads
with huge huge huge capacity if you want
to run microservices you know that is a
native support for docker in the cloud
then ECS is the service that does that
you don't have to install it you can
operate and scale your own cluster in
the cloud and it's all a managed service
open to you now let's say you are
focused only on writing code you are a
developer or you want your team to focus
only on writing code you do not want to
worry about the infrastructure part of
your application then AWS lambda is the
service that is the function as a
service so you don't have to worry about
the infrastructure at all
AWS simply tells you that you give me
the code you tell me how much memory you
are going to need and all I'm going to
Bill you for is the time your function
is going to take to run in the cloud and
I think it's an amazing thing if you've
heard about the term serverless this is
what serverless is
[Music]
so we are going to take a look at the
demo of this service as well so let's go
back to console and see if we can take a
look at ec2 so here I am on the ec2
console and if you see here this is my
region and I am in US East not in
Virginia region
now we are at ec2 dashboard and let's
look at how we can launch an instance
now before we start let's take a look at
the regions so I am in u.s. East
northern Virginian region and these are
all the regions that you can choose from
and this is where I'm going to launch my
ec2 instance the first thing that I'm
going to do when I'm going to launch my
instance on the server in cloud is
choose an image which is known as Amazon
machine image ami and this is nothing
but the software package so I'll go
ahead and I'll choose the default option
that I get over here and you can see
that it has the command-line tools
Python Ruby pearl Java docker PHP MySQL
so you could have anything that you want
and then I'll go ahead and I'll select
this once I have selected this I'm going
to choose my instance type on hardware
and you can see that right now I have a
t2 dot micro which simply is three-tier
eligible and the network performance is
kind of low to moderate but if I scroll
down you can see the network performance
and everything else goes way up and then
I can go and have a different purpose
compute memory FPGA the graphics
anything that I want and this is the
variety of services you get with AWS
next step is to configure my install
details so I could have one or more
instances this is my networking so
essentially where do I want to put it do
I want to put it in my network or the V
PC that I have created or do you want it
in another V PC vbc is nothing but your
isolated cloud your network inside the
cloud apart from that I can put
something called advanced details which
is nothing but boot up JavaScript so if
you want something to run when your ec2
instance is provision when it starts
this is where you are going to put that
so for the purpose of the demo I'll keep
it where it is and move on to the next
step which is storage
so essentially your hard drive the root
volume is nothing it is the hard drive
where your OS is installed and then I
can add any more hard drives that I want
and then I can change the size of it if
I want it to be encrypted I can do that
as well so let's keep it simple and move
to the next step which is tags now tags
are used for identification purposes
let's say you have many teams there's a
Java team a darknet team and you want to
keep track of who is using all the
resources so this is where you can add
tags that say name equals dark net team
and this is how you are going to
identify who has launched this thing
next up we have security groups these
are instance level firewalls so
firewalls for your server so typically
if you want to allow an SSH if you want
to allow an HTTP at HTTP access this is
where you are going to go to add the
firewall rules and you can put the
source as anywhere which means anyone
from the internet can access this thing
now I do not want SSH access for
everybody so I just keep it HTTP and
HTTPS the SSH access will be essentially
for my people that I want and that's
about it
I go and I'll say review and launch and
we can review all of the settings that
we have here over here and we will
simply launch and now it's going to ask
for my keypad this is now something that
is required of me to SSH into this
particular instance and I'll simply say
that yes I have access to this thing and
it will launch the instance that's about
it it's as simple as that to launch your
ec2 instance in cloud and if I come on
the dashboard I can see that my instance
is being provisioned and I have all the
information I need over here then if I
want more information I can click over
here and I can get all of the
information that I want over here
moreover I have these status checks so
there are two types of status checks
that check the health of the instance so
it will make sure that everything all of
the AWS resources that are required to
keep this resource up and running are
running sign and it will also see if I
have something that is not required in
my instance it is also there to make it
up and running
now that our instance is up and running
I can click on it and I can connect
using the console so I don't have to use
a command prompt I can click on the
console itself and I can do whatever I
want on the other hand if I take the IP
address and if I go here there it is out
of the box I see my wordpress site up
and running I don't have to do anything
it is right there for me to use and I
can just customize it any which way that
I want let's see if I can have the SSH
window open here and I can just use the
login credentials that I have there it
is I can simply log into this and start
playing around with it I can also see
all the metrics I can see the networking
I can take a snapshot I can do pretty
much whatever I want this is something
that if you have your own virtual
private server in the cloud with all the
resources that you need you can run your
small applications on it you can run
your WordPress site on it you can do so
many things there are so many use cases
that you can use lightsail for it is one
of the most popular compute services
that was recently launched let's look at
lambda so we come to compute and then we
click on lambda this essentially
functions as a service you can see that
I already have something that is already
there so let's create a lambda function
we'll take something that is provided
out-of-the-box for us you just click on
this and then we click on an SNS message
so this is like the messaging service of
AWS simple notification services
and we can enable trigger the SNS topic
is incident response and let's click on
it now you can see I can type my
function name so I'll simply say
[Music]
my lambda function
and the language that I'm choosing edge
node J s I can also have c-sharp Java
Python etc and this is my simple code
and then I have environment variables I
can use I will create a new role and
then I will name my new role
my lambda SNS role
I'll keep everything as it is and that I
would simply say go next then I'll
create a function now this function
would be using some memory and this
function will take some amount of time
to execute that amount of time is what
AWS is going to charge me for
I do not get charged for anything else
so here my lambda function is ready and
if I click on test then I can simply say
you
you
there it is SNS
say and test and it should give me
something that says hello from SNS
let's look at this function at the
detail that we got if you see here that
is the duration so it ran 42.84
milliseconds and then the billing
duration or the bill duration is 100
milliseconds the resources configure so
I said that I needed 128 MB of RAM to
run this thing and the maximum memory
that I actually used that this function
actually used was 90 megabytes so that
is all I need to do I need to upload my
code and then I need to say how much
memory I'm going to use and it can be up
to 512 MB there's only one more
limitation that says that our function
should not run for more than five
minutes essentially a micro service
would not necessarily run for 5 minutes
if it's running for more than 5 minutes
then it's probably the best idea to
break it down into several more
functions we get build by milliseconds
and the best part is in the first year
you get something like 1 billion
milliseconds available in the first year
go and test this thing this is one of
the most interesting things that you
will find as a developer as an
organization you want your people to
focus on the code you know how easily
you can push your code to production to
the customers and you don't want to
worry about infrastructure so this is
one service that is really worth
exploring let's take a closer look at
lightsail the newest addition to compute
now this is one of those things which
will give you a complete package it
starts at less than $5 a month so let's
create an instance and right now I am in
the Mumbai region and I can change my
region so let's put it in to Virginia
we can pick up our instance image if I
want only OS operating system I can do
that if I want apps and OS I can do that
as well so I'll keep it to WordPress I
want to make a WordPress website on my
server I can add any script that I want
to fire at the bootstrap I can also have
the SSH keypad that I will use to log in
from the console for lightsail and then
depending on how many resources I need I
can choose my instance plan and it goes
all the way from $5 a month
to $80 a month if I'm running some
really heavy-duty application on it but
because I'm only running my WordPress
website I simply need the basic one
then I am very good with 512mb RAM one
CPU and one terabyte of data transfer
then I want to name my instance and I'll
keep it the way it is and here I can
change the quantity as well if I click
on it then that's about it that's about
all I need to do to have my instance up
and running right now it is an appending
state now this is something that is
really good for the virtual private
server I don't have to worry about ec2
instance I don't have to worry about
security patches I don't have to worry
about the firewalls it's all available
to me in one small box so all I do is
come here I click a few things and my
instance is up and ready hey once you
become an expert in cloud computing then
subscribe to simpler Channel and click
here to watch more such videos turner it
up and get certified in cloud computing
click here